all right y'all i bet a lot of you have
just recently started or are about to
start a new job in tech so i know i
actually went back to software
engineering so yes this actually
includes me and i will be making another
video about this and no matter how the
times have changed or what technologies
are being used or what companies are at
the top starting a new job is always
scary thoughts might include but are not
limited to
what should i prepare how should i even
prepare what if i don't get along with
my coworkers what if i can't keep up and
like learn all the things in time do
they make the right decision hiring me
am i
ready these are all thoughts that i've
had at every job that i started and let
me tell you from the get-go all of these
feelings and thoughts are very natural
and a normal part of the process and you
know on this channel i like talking
about the feelings that arise as a
person who works in tech and so today i
wanted to help you all who are
navigating this currently and this is
just something that everybody goes
through prepping for that first day
slash week slash months on the job so i
hope this helps you out and so in order
to talk about this today i've actually
invited a few other people who've gone
through this recently to share their
perspectives to kind of supplement and
tell a full story that it's not just me
it's not just you there's a bunch of
other people out there who are
experiencing and thinking these same
things and before we move on i want to
say a quick thank you to formation for
sponsoring today's video so for those of
you who don't know what formation is if
you're an engineer with one to two years
of experience and you're looking to
really level up your engineering skills
to land your dream job then definitely
check out the formation fellowship
formation was founded by staff level
engineers at facebook and nextdoor who
interviewed thousands of candidates and
wanted a better way to prepare engineers
to perform at a fang level bar
once you apply and get accepted into the
fellowship you get a personalized
training plan to fill your specific
skill gaps you get direct mentorship
from super senior engineers and you get
referrals directly into the top
companies in the industry in fact i
partnered with them to create a myuco x
formation diversity scholarship it was
really meaningful that i got to do this
with them because we got to cover the
full tuition of one person's cost into
the fellowship program and as a result
we've received 113 applications and
we're going to announce the winners in
mid-september which is very very soon in
fact in the application we actually
asked about career transitions and
reading these responses really reminded
us that it's never too late to pursue
your dream and we really appreciate the
applicants were so open and vulnerable
with us like these stories were really
inspiring to read so thank you so much
to everyone who applied and also for
formation for doing the scholarship
their fellowship program is still
ongoing so if you're interested you can
apply for free on their website at
formation.dev and whether or not you get
in you'll get some invaluable career
advice from an engineering mentor and a
free prep guide that's a really helpful
resource to prepare you for faying level
interviews thank you again information
for sponsoring and now let's get back to
the video i think starting a new job in
tech is honestly like really similar to
starting that first day of school it was
pretty much like the first day of school
right like i kind of just psyched myself
up i was ready to go i had my uniform
out the day before right that's louise
after he graduated from the formation
fellowship he landed a software
engineering job at capital one after a
career in theater and the arts it was my
first software engineering role having
no idea what it's like to really be in
order to have like a day in the life of
a software engineer
i think everything as far as like what's
the day-to-day was completely new and
something i had to adjust to
and that's aidan who's also a formation
graduate who started a new software
engineering job about seven months ago i
kind of tried my best to just make sure
that my nerves were put to the side
because you know kind of like anything
that you're starting that's new you
really kind of just want to soak in
everything that's coming at you so yeah
let's talk about those nerves first
because like that's the biggest thing
like how do you deal with it i think
it's okay to be scared because i think
the nerves are good because it means
you're excited if you were dead inside
and you're starting a new job then maybe
there's a problem where you're like not
excited about this thing and that's
selena who's the head of recruitment at
formation who previously has helped
thousands of interns adjust to their
first day of work at facebook now when
it comes to nerves there's a lot of
techniques that people use to try to
calm down things like deep breathing and
meditation and visualization techniques
like i've used them too and sometimes
you just have to like sit through those
uncomfortable feelings and wait for them
to go away after maybe like a couple of
weeks of working there you just get used
to it i asked selena about this because
again she's seen thousands of people
start their first day she said she even
saw some people get on the wrong bus so
i really love what she had to say i
think you can
put those fears and that those nerves
into practice of like i'm really excited
what do i do with this excitement i'm
gonna go meet a bunch of people at my
new company and like ask a bunch of
questions and get to know people and
that's like you could you know turn that
fear into excitement versus like maybe
that it's just the nerves are neutral
you know everybody's
like starts off as a new person you
obviously remember being new at school
or knew you've had that experience over
and over and over again but you know it
it subsides it oh like you just take it
one step at a time like after the first
week you're no longer the newest person
at the company now one of the things you
can do to deal with these nerves is to
manage your expectations because one of
the reasons why i think it's like really
scary to start a new job is because you
don't know what they expect of you and
you don't know what to expect of them
there's just like so much ambiguity in
the air that probably it just turns into
fear and the good news is the more that
you switch jobs or like the more you see
people go through their first day you
kind of realize what those expectations
are so in the first week or so of your
job most teams are not expecting you to
make like a meaningful contribution yet
in fact you'll probably be spending that
first week just like setting up your
environment because yes it can take that
long well for sure i think one of the
big things was how long tech was gonna
take to be installed because uh yeah
there were a lot of hiccups and then
just like it took a lot of that uh that
onboarding week to just you know
download a lot of different things and
to make sure i had all the right uh
again technologies and it might be a
little bit challenging to like get
everything set up and running and get
started but like there's going to be
people that can help you so if you've
ever heard of or like felt the need to
like make your very first pull request
in that first week like don't worry
there's usually not that expectation and
if you do end up creating a pull request
or something it'll likely be for
something really small and easy to kind
of show you how the pull requests work
it's actually more of a risk for you to
start contributing to things without
really knowing how everything works
together yet there's this like feeling
of
needing to be productive at the
beginning
that i think we just innately have as
workers like you feel good when you can
ship something out or that you can
contribute to something and it's kind of
an uncomfortable awkward feeling when
they don't expect that of you like you
want to jump in and you want to start
coding right away but actually
they want you to like wait they don't
give you projects right away they want
you to like sit in sort of
like a student and learning space where
they're like you need to learn how to do
this stuff before we actually give you
stuff to do
and this is not a time for working this
is a time of actually like
sponge absorbing learning
and just watching how things get played
out and it kind of feels weird
because you feel like why are you paying
me i'm not doing anything or like i'm
not actually doing any work and i feel
kind of weird about that you feel like
you're doing a bad job because you're
not producing anything the expectation
is not to produce right away and so yeah
that first week is really about getting
set up and learning depending on the
company that can actually stretch into
like the first few months at netflix in
fact my manager told me that like for
the first six months she's not expecting
me to make any huge contributions and
instead to spend that time to really
learn about the code base the product
and the people that i'm gonna be working
with so then the next six months are
gonna be really productive and so yeah
that kind of timeline of is it a few
weeks or is it a few months that's
something that can be really helpful to
ask your manager during that first week
of the job so like ask your manager ask
your team like how like what's the ramp
up time like
how many weeks do i have to ramp up and
what's your expectation of me at the end
of that ramp up period like do you
expect me to have like tasks out by x
date or whatever and just set those
expectations so you just know when you
need to start actually getting
productive but wait shouldn't you
actually know how to do the job when you
start the job there's definitely this
notion that like when you get hired and
started the job like you know the ins
and outs of it and you know how to do
the thing already i mean that's what
they assess you on in the interview
right i think
my manager's manager uh kind of clued me
in on what to expect in my new role as
far as like technologies and you know
the tech stack at
gopuff and
so
when i first joined i was like okay i
got to learn everything about the tech
stack and i got to make sure that i'm
like really good at i think it was like
graphql and
node.js and
these different various technologies so
that was the first thing that i kind of
did to prepare myself but realistically
that's not true i think you have to get
it through your head that the first
couple weeks of your job are not the
interview you already interviewed you
already proved that they like you they
want to hire you they were eager to hire
you they gave you the you know the
salary all of it's already yours you're
not interviewing in your first few weeks
that's already done illegal to work
before your start date because they're
not paying you then they have to like
work out how to pay you those like for
that extra work that you did even if you
don't know all the code bases and all
the languages that this new company is
like you know maybe you're it's a
different stack learning that stack
might not be that helpful either because
they might do it in a way that is not
like
the same as by the book
at facebook it was like that where like
ios and android was completely different
internally than it was like if you were
to take a class so it actually is not
helpful so you might just be wasting
your time which yeah like every company
every team
builds differently even if the
technologies listed are the same the way
that they get used is usually really
different and so that's honestly what
makes working at each company really
unique i mean aiden studied some stuff
before he started his job and then when
he got to his job he was told to study
and learn something completely different
is that likes just surprised on the
first day or whatever when i had my
uh
you know initial meeting with my manager
or whatever
when he basically told me like
oh yeah so the first thing i want you to
learn is flutter i was like wait i
wasn't on the list
of things that i was expecting to uh to
know
but something i learned from selena is
that it's actually literally illegal for
companies to force you to study and
learn things before you start the job so
if that makes you feel less guilty about
not doing the summer homework before
school starts then hopefully that helps
but of course if it's something that you
want to do then i'm sure that it will
not hurt but even then there's going to
be a lot of company-specific stuff that
you need to learn on the job which
you're not going to be able to google so
no matter how much you study before the
job there's still going to be a lot more
that you have to learn once you get
there and yes this is where that golden
rule comes up about starting a new job
in tech and that's to ask lots of
questions tip number one is ask
questions at the beginning because no
one expects you to know things no one's
testing you on like who founded this
company what year or whatever
nobody's
no one's there like trying to quiz you
or anything like there's
they already made the hire they wanted
to hire you
they already made the decision like yes
we like this person you already went
through all the interviews that's
different you just have to ask you know
you might be given a small task just to
like practice how to use their code base
and like understand like oh this is how
the code review process works it's not
necessarily about the task itself or
being able to independently do all this
stuff but
it's really like we want you to learn
the process how to work with the team
how to do the code reviews the way that
we do them
and to just you know go through the flow
of it and then
you know
it'll it'll kind of you'll get into the
groove where you don't feel like you
have to ask about every single thing but
in the the beginning of working at a new
place you should ask tons of questions
you shouldn't hide your questions from
your manager because you're afraid to
feel dumb that's like
tip number one is ask questions at the
beginning because no one expects you to
know things and yeah this tracks i've
been on five different ios teams and
while over time i was able to identify
that there were patterns to how things
were built and shipped and stuff like
that each of them did things a little
bit differently that i really needed to
pay attention to the process and how
things were done in each company to make
sure that i wasn't breaking things and
to be like an effective member of the
team not to mention all of these
companies are in like very different
parts of the industry but also all the
people that i worked with at each
company were very different and i need
to figure out how i can work with them
and asking questions i know that it
sounds scary to like sound dumb or
whatever but i think it really shows
that you're a curious person that you
have some humility and that you're
really eager to learn making the career
switch for myself like
there's a lot of times where the
imposter syndrome kind of settles in
right and so i'm just like okay you know
i'm afraid to ask the question but at
the same time you know i kind of have to
bite the ball and be like hey you know
what is this how how can i achieve this
because the reality is i i don't know
and especially to working with other
members on my team who've been doing
this for a while it's you know it
sometimes can be a little intimidating
because as much as i am an overthinker
right i'm always like okay well what if
i ask this well i don't want them to
think that i'm you know like uh the
bottom of the bar or anything but at the
same time like if i don't ask the
question i'm not gonna know i've
definitely had experiences where i went
weeks without asking what like something
meant i didn't really understand the
conversations that were happening around
me and then when i stopped for a second
i was like hey i don't get this and then
someone explained it to me then i was
actually able to participate in those
conversations and get what's going on
and most people are not gonna judge you
for this and if they do maybe don't go
to that person for questions but i trust
you there are gonna be so many people
who are willing to help and at the end
of the day it's okay to make mistakes
too allow yourself the grace that you're
not gonna have everything figured out in
the first week because trust me nobody
ever does while it's uncomfortable to be
in this phase of like being in training
i think it can really help to have the
mindset that you're actually exactly
where you're supposed to be like it's
literally your job to be in training
just
try to enjoy
the time where you don't have a ton of
projects and you don't have
a ton on your plate because that'll
never happen again at that company those
first few weeks that's the only time
where you have no responsibilities
except learning so just
focus on learning don't try to like
speed up and like you know jump past it
and start working and being productive
it's like you'll have the rest of your
career there to do those things i just
can't stress enough to
to just allow yourself to
to not well to allow yourself to be okay
with messing up
right because
i can't tell you how many times i've
been there like afraid to to make the
wrong step and instead like i end up
either not doing it or in the end it's
not even a big deal because my teammates
will be like or tim uh yeah my team
members will be like oh you know like oh
i've done that before or like oh you
know like um you know it's not a big
deal like it's it's okay and lastly i
want to recognize that a lot of us are
starting jobs in remote environments
which we're all still kind of getting
used to and starting at a job where
you're not going to like naturally bump
into your co-workers or have lunch with
them every day and talk about stuff
poses a challenge for how you're going
to build personal relationships with
your teammates i think just being a
remote that's just been a huge
challenge because even though it's nice
to just
you know be able to kind of roll out of
bed and be able to just kind of hop on
my computer or go to my stand-up or
whatever the case may be
you know not having that personal
interaction sometimes can be a little
difficult organically like when you were
at an in-person company
you're able to like meet people for
coffee and doing all these things to
like you get to know people outside of
like the meeting the work meeting and
now you don't have any time with people
outside of the work meeting i think if
you're in like a remote environment it's
really hard
to make remote friends with people at
work so try to bring your whole self and
like you know don't bring your like
linkedin version of yourself
to the office you know you can share a
little bit about who you are and like
that's kind of how you make friends i
found that like joining meetings early
or even just spending the first five
minutes just like talk about non-work
stuff or staying afterwards to do so or
just like finding time to just like
connect with your co-workers in some way
is really helpful of course do so when
it's appropriate but it's a great way to
make connections and a lot of people
recommend setting up these like
one-on-one meetings where it's just the
two of you for either 30 minutes or an
hour to not only get to know their work
and their role but get to know them as
human beings as people it definitely
takes a lot more effort to make those
connections now that remote work is more
common but i really do think that your
experience at a company is really like
made by the people that you work with
and so definitely worth getting to know
them so that's it for this video thank
you so much for watching thank you to
selena luis and aiden for letting me
interview you and sharing your
perspectives with everybody if you're
starting a new job in tech then let me
know in the comments down below what
makes you nervous what are you scared
about what's helped you to kind of calm
down your nerves and if you're
interested in learning why i went back
to software engineering then make sure
to subscribe to this channel because
that video is coming soon alright thanks
again for watching and i'll see you next
time bye